but we're going to begin with a very
scary and very terrifying story about
The Deadly storms in the South they are
wreaking the same system that's wreaked
havoc in California in recent days this
is a monster it seems tornadoes have
ripped through multiple States from
Alabama to South Carolina and at least
seven people have died you can see here
how these Twisters respond as a system
and as they developed Omar villafrancas
in hard hit Marbury Alabama in a county
where the death toll has reached at
least six people there Omar good morning
to you
good morning this area was hit by one of
several tornadoes from that storm we
want to show you some of the destruction
the first thing you notice is all the
trees we even smell the pine trees as we
were coming up here under the scene
uprooted Twisted together and broken
apart the more you look you start seeing
pieces of homes we see a little bit of a
bed frame over there some cabinets
there's even somebody's wheelchair
that's right here next to us another
thing that we are starting to notice is
vehicles and farm equipment and it's
almost as if this whole neighborhood was
basically picked up thrown into a
blender put on high and then spit out
it's all part of a 20 mile path of
destruction
oh my God shock and fear as a funnel
cloud Roars into sight
one of 35 reported tornadoes to strike
the South Thursday oh my God this is the
building beside us I Can't Describe is
it bad Montreal caves uncle and at least
five others were killed when a reported
tornado destroyed roughly 40 homes
shearing off roofs and shredding walls
oh I have mercy officials say the same
tornado also ripped through Selma
Alabama while in Greensboro this was my
mom's house y'all this storm in the
Atlanta area was reduced to a pile of
bricks and cinder blocks that stuff can
be fixed but I'm glad nobody got hurt
the roof of this house in Griffin
Georgia landed on a vehicle parked
outside the powerful Gus uprooted trees
and overturned big rigs on highways
across the South there's been millions
of dollars in damage crews in
communities like Oak Village Alabama are
picking up the pieces after being
decimated I've lost everything that I
own but other than that I've got my life
we also learned that in Georgia a
six-year-old boy was killed when the car
he was in was hit by a tree now back
here in Marbury search and rescue will
continue in fact you might be able to
see some of the headlights behind me
that's the search and rescue teams that
are waiting when the sun comes back up
they're going to continue uh their
search mission out here we've already
seen power crews out here trying to
restore power but cleanup here is going
to take weeks Nate
Omar thank you